well let's talk now to someone else who
is inside that service dorian sonobari
who holds her bronze silver and gold
duke of edinburgh awards and gave a
tribute to prince philip's legacy at the
service earlier a lot of people have
talked about
your tribute and the fact that it was at
the very beginning of the service and
this jukebender award ceremony was
something
that the family wanted him to be
remembered for
so well done because i imagine that was
absolutely terrifying
what difference did the duke of
edinburgh award make to your life
for me the duke of edinburgh's award um
helped to open new opportunities for me
um i spoke about it in my tribute but i
wouldn't have gotten my first job at 18
if it wasn't for the duke thunderbirds
award why is that what was it you did
that
um because when you're asked questions
in interviews or cvs when you're trying
to give examples of what you've done
you need experience for that and i
didn't have any professional experience
but i was able to say look i've shown
examples of teamwork when i did my
expedition in wales you know i've taken
initiative by doing all of these
programs or um volunteering in the
community and that kind of helps to show
the kind of person i am and my
willingness to learn and that's what
helped me land my first job in in the
technology sector
where did you come to the duke of
edinburgh awards where did you hear
about them what did you think about them
when you first heard about them um i
didn't quite understand it i just
thought it was something that people did
where they went outside and went camping
i wasn't really keen on it and my mom
was definitely the one that encouraged
me to do it and i really used the word
encouraged strongly because i didn't
have a choice
but i'm glad that she did i really am
i'm grateful for that and i'm grateful
that i learned that it was more about
trying new things but being recognized
for those new things as well
and did you get to meet the duke of
edinburgh yes i met him once and
they were opening the new duke of
venomous
so it was very brief encounter but he
was lovely he didn't make any gaffes
thank goodness not on that occasion what
did you think when you were asked to
to make this this statement and this
tribute today
um i thought it was an honor um
especially as a way of thanking the duke
because i don't think i've ever got to
thank him in person but just to share
his legacy and his story to the world
but also to show how it's impacting
millions of young people and i just
found that honor and i'm really glad
that i was able to give the tribute
today
and and going back to the duke of
edinburgh award you know you said it
gave you confidence when it when it came
to applying for jobs and
how else did it help you do you think
i think it helps me in terms of
realizing that there's no one way of
doing things
um at the time i was very sort of
a traditional person if that makes sense
so i thought okay you go to school and
you go to union and you find a job and
so for me
kind of having to have a gap year scheme
before going to university and then kind
of seeing the world of technology and
other things that i could do sort of
help to broaden my horizons i think it's
really great the award allows young
people to experience that and that was
of course exactly what the duke
edinburgh wanted it to be about wasn't
it it was about showing
people that it was a different way
what was it like seeing all the members
of the royal family there
it's a real scene of a person
yeah
you weren't too nervous
no no i wasn't honestly um
yeah i know they're lovely so
well well done it must have been really
nerve-wracking you've just done all the
media as well you must be absolutely
frozen
doing sombari great to see you thank you
very much thank you